well u.s backed forces are closing in on
the last sliver of isis territory
in syria this morning they say isis
controls only about a
one square mile in the eastern village
of bagooz
charlie dagetta reports from the front
lines of this offensive that is now
entering its final stages
cell phone footage of fierce gun battles
shows what they've been up against
isis militants firing back with
everything they had left
but on the front line thursday we found
a change
soldiers at ease sensing victory
that is the village of bacoose vikani
isis's last stand
and apart from sporadic gunfire all you
can hear now
is silence hundreds of isis fighters
have reportedly surrendered in the past
48 hours
as many as half the estimated number
left
american aid worker david eubank said he
saw dozens give themselves up to u.s
special forces right here
we saw a group of about 50 men all fit
strong looking guys
walking with like three women they
searched them all they were all isis
fighters that gave up
the u.s led coalition has released a
statement saying while
isis is on the verge of collapse and the
end of the physical
caliphate is at hand they continue to
pose a threat to the security of this
region
for cbs this morning charlie dagda in
eastern syria